في رجل صيني اسمه ليو هربان من الشرطه من
14 سنه ومتخبي في كهف ضمن غابه ولكنه
اخيرا مل من حياه الهاربين وسلم نفسه
للشركه لانه يبغى يعيش حياه طبيعيه مثل
غيره مو هنا القصه القصه ايش السبب اللي
خلاه يهرب ويتخبى في كهف وسط الغابه 14
سنه هذا اللي راح يصدمكم فعلا ويمكن ما
تصدقون السبب انه لي وقت كان عمره في
الثلاثينات شارك في عمليه سطو على محطه
وقود هو وصهر وشريك ثالث وسرقوا من المحطه
مبلغ مالي كما المبلغ يا جماعه 23 دولار
نعم 23 دولار هذا المبلغ الكامل بس وقت ما
تعرفوا كمان المبلغ اللي طلع له لحاله من
كل السرقه يمكن تنهاره فمن بعد ما اكلوا
وشربوا العاب ناريه طلع لكل واحد منهم
اربع دولارات الحمد لله ومن بعدها رجعوا
للبيت لكن الشرطه قبضت على صهره وشريكم
الثالث علشان كذا الاخ ليو هرب على الغابه
وسكن في كهف 14 سنه وكان بيتسل ل على
القريه عشان يشوف اهله وياخذ اكل وشرب
وبعض 14 سنه من الحبس اللي هو حبس نفسه
بنفسه في مثل ما شايفين وعلى فكره كل اللي
عملوه في نفسه هذا وسنوات الهروب هذه كلها
الطويله ما حتخليه ينفذ من العقوبه لانه
لسه بيواجهوا عقوبه يمكن توصل لعشر سنين
سجن يعني لو كان حبيبي من وقت اسلم نفسه
كان اهون عليه من السجن مرتين له 14 سنه
وعشر سنين ثانيه يعني